this video has been a long time coming i
got a professional investor to come on
the show and tell us what he thinks
of all these ridiculous fake gurus i
wanted to know do these
professional investors people who run
hedge funds people who are institutional
investors do they actually respect
people like ricky gutierrez tim sykes
are these actual
traders that you should listen to or are
they just frauds
so you're going to hear it straight from
an actual professional investor forget
about these 20 year olds
on their little laptops telling you that
it's so easy just spend an hour with us
come on
you know i know you guys like to see the
lambos we don't have any of that for you
i know you guys want to see the nice
houses we don't have any of that for you
what we do have is somebody who has
spent his life in the stock market
and he's going to tell you that not
everything you've been told is gold so
please enjoy this hour-long video and uh
i'll see you in the next one
welcome to coffeezilla today guys we
have patrick
boyle patrick you've been an
institutional investor for
over 20 years you teach at university in
the uk and you're now
a hedge fund manager is that correct yes
that's correct yeah
and on top of that you have a finance
youtube channel
which is criminally undersubscribed to
um because you talk about you know
a bunch of interesting real finance
topics
not how to make 500 in a day you're
actually trying to educate people
on how to trade you know with a
quantitative approach
uh and you reached out because you said
look um
we were talking about something i had
said about day trading
but i said hey why don't you come on the
show and talk to people because
obviously
you understand trading at a higher level
than probably 99
of any of these youtubers or coaches or
anything like that
and so i'd like to talk to you about
reasonable expectations for people who
are getting in the stock market
um reasonable expectations for how to
know if somebody's selling you something
rather than actually giving you a real
education
and uh we'll go from there but let's
just start off
as someone who's been on the
institutional side now you're on the
hedge fund side you
teach this stuff at a university level
what do you think the state of education
is with trading
on youtube right now you know it's
interesting because there are
there are some good channels out there
that i quite enjoy like that that kind
of just give
a good explanation of um sort of what
various products are i think
you know there's a fairly obvious uh
differentiation between the people who
are telling you how to get rich and the
people explaining things to you
and i would argue in a funny way i think
that you know the sort of fake guru
thing is not just
a an investment world or a money-making
thing it's
it's there everywhere like in that you
know and some of it relates as you said
reasonable expectations like if you you
know you'll see uh
someone telling you you know how to lose
50 pounds in
in two weeks and have a you know
six-pack abs or
how to learn the guitar in one easy
lesson and
you know all of these things like you
have to sort of ask yourself is it
reasonable like these
you know like like is it reasonable to
think that someone could very quickly
within a few weeks tell me how to do
this sort of thing
yeah and i think though the problem with
stocks is that with weight loss it's
pretty
easy for most people to understand why
that's unrealistic the stock market's
much more complicated and most people
who have no experience with the stock
market
might very well be taken in by the idea
that like
oh yeah it's reasonable to expect i'm
making two percent a day
and that's like a reasonable rate of
return
can you talk about what should people be
expecting for day trading what is an
excellent return and what's just like
that doesn't happen
let's actually start just with that two
percent a day argument because that's
kind of a slightly comical one you know
if you think about it it might sound
reasonable to someone initially like if
you say well if you
took something and bought it for a
hundred dollars and sold it for a
hundred and two dollars that sounds
within the range of reasonable
expectations but if
if we then kind of annualize it out you
know if you take
two percent a day that would turn into
about i don't know 140
000 percent a year roughly like that
that's what you're talking about
um and in three years you could take
your hundred
dollars and that would that would make
you
probably about 16 times wealthier than
jeff
bezos for example it would make you in
if you were 16 times wealthier than just
basis you're actually
would be probably wealthier than the 100
wealthiest people in the world
combined right and so two percent
a day you know when you kind of go oh
well i bought something for a hundred
and solder 102
now i'll do that every day that that's
not how
the world works you know um
a good example like when i i looked up
like some of the returns of the the
greatest investors of all time so
people like george soros and warren
buffett have probably the best records
out there
and you know a lot of people kind of go
oh buffett it's boring or at least if
sort of fake gurus would but warren
buffett and george soros have each
returned about 20
a year over 40 years you know which is
about twice the return of the market you
know so that's
amazing returns to to have gotten away
with
um steve cohen of sac capital
returned around 30 a year over a much
shorter time frame
and it's worth noting that he has been
banned from trading client money
by the sec and you know there are i
don't know that anything is proven but
there have been questions around
his uh his trading that's certainly
worth noting
let me say though so what these people
will say to
this when i when i say this or when you
say this they go hey well that's because
you're talking about people handling
very large accounts
and my genius strategy that's making me
two percent a day consistently
just doesn't work on that scale and
that's why i can only make
i'm only making like let's say they say
they make a hundred thousand five
hundred thousand dollars a year
they go so i this is like a tim sykes
things i can really take people from
trading
with like nothing to trading about a one
million to two million account size
but after that my strategies don't work
which is why i'm not
uh you know i'm not a warren buffett
that's what they'll say
what would you say there is something
there in that even the the fund palomar
that i run
um you know we capped the amount of
investor money we would take in because
we're doing short-term strategies
and that means they're less scalable but
the nature of something being less
scalable
also makes it less shareable right
because
why would you take something if he's
able to turn we'll say
a thousand dollars into a million in a
year and then continue
continually trade that why would he ever
give that to
to the public and and it's not even it's
not like you ran into him and he's a
friend of yours and he offered to help
you out with this advice
right like when you search if you just
google like
great trading strategies like the first
10 odds will be from these guys right
like so
not only are they you know not only are
they
they willing to give it away but they're
willing to spend money on
ads to tell you that they'll give it
away to you so in other words if it's a
strategy
that is limited in scale
that doesn't make any sense because
they're they're paying good money to
scale it to the moon
yes okay well not not only that it's
actually even an interesting thing is
because what i
run is sort of quantitative strategies
and what that essentially means
is that i take a lot of data and i
analyze them and look for opportunities
within the market that uh
that you know in theory work repeatedly
now
now you the the what you actually find
them when you do that is you find a mix
of strategies that work quite well
and you find other ones that look like
they will work quite well but then they
don't
out of sample and it's it's always
difficult to differentiate between those
before uh
you know on day one but the nature of
those kinds of strategies as i've said
they're usually not scalable
and so you keep them as a secret you
know and you keep them as a secret not
even out of a lack of generosity
but it's a lot of work for me to find a
good trading strategy
and if i even if i worked in offices
with great people and they've sort of
said to me like oh could you explain how
this works and it's like i can't tell
you that because then
everyone will do it and then it won't
work you know because that's the nature
of some you know
actually the first guy i worked with the
first kind of
really interesting uh fun manager was a
guy named victor niederhoffer who wrote
a great book called education of a
speculator
and in the opening of the book he he
basically says
there will be no trading secrets in here
because if i
could tell you this sort of thing why
would i tell you that and put myself at
a disadvantage and return myself to
being a mere mortal you know struggling
to feed himself
you know and so you know and actually an
interesting one because when i did start
that job i was
around 20 years old and i remember kind
of arriving in the office with a guy who
i knew
had you know he had run sources quantum
fund
throughout the 1980s you know under
periods of huge returns
and i kind of thought you know like this
is great i'll sit here and he will teach
me his
ways you know and instead he sat me down
he said there's a computer
there's a there's a load of data go and
find a good trade because he didn't hire
me to teach me stuff
he hired me to find stuff that he could
find useful and that's
kind of the nature of any of this stuff
like when
when people look at my youtube channel i
often try to explain
unusual technical things in the market
like one of my bigger videos was a while
ago
when oil prices had gone negative it was
all over the newspaper oil prices were
negative
and what i tried to explain in the video
was
how sort of the nature of the futures
market
means that that the that
when you're buying and selling oil
futures you're not really buying
oil that's in the ground you're buying
oil that expires at a certain time and
so therefore the
the price relates to storage costs and
all these other things and
you know i put up this video and it did
well but a funny thing is a lot of the
people in the comment section then
wanted me to say
well should i buy oil or not and it's
like no no
i'm not telling you what to do because
if i tell you to buy something
you don't have to come back to me and be
told when to sell it right like i'm i'm
explaining how it works and once you arm
yourself with all of these ideas
you're better able to make decisions you
know what you understand the products
you're trading better and that that's
kind of my goal with my channel
right no and i think that's the nature
of real education is not like okay tell
me what to do
now i'm gonna do it and i'm gonna come
back to you and now you tell me what to
do again and i'm gonna do it and then
i'm gonna do it again
uh and i think a lot of these things end
up
sort of also being a bit of pyramid
schemes
where these people they give signals to
their audience
who then rushes out and buys the thing
and they sell it on they sell it on the
way up
like the person that's sort of the
oldest scheme in the world you know
you read you know one of the things i
would advise people
if they want to learn about investing
and trading
is to read a lot of books and there's
books going back hundreds of years on
the idea of financial speculation or
investing or
whatever it might be and these tricks
are all
as old as the hills you know these guys
have been around forever
um it's just kind of a new coat of paint
is what you're saying
it's just exactly like it's just you
know there's there's uh
there's nothing necessarily that new
about about their claims
but uh you know the pump and dump scheme
is basically what you're describing
there
and you know it's it's a thing that's
been around forever
it you know the internet gives it new
life because you're able to reach
more people over the internet than
you're able to reach but
interestingly enough one of the things
we first started chatting about was
jordan belfort the
the wolf of wall street you know who is
now i guess
setting himself up as a an investing
guru of some sort
he's joined ragingbull.com for those of
you who don't know
which is under ownership by this guy
jeff bishop i believe
or here let me look it up real quick
raging bull
and i know interestingly enough you know
i i see the ads once again all over
youtube
the funny thing is if you create
financial content you get financial ads
and they tend to all be sort of
questionable ads i would say
and you know jeff bishop is one of these
guys you know
kind of getting on an airplane with wads
of
cash you know like for some reason like
when when i invest in the market and i
make a profit
it usually turns up in my account well
their brokers seem to drop off these
large
bags of cash that they then have to take
on a private jet
you know to to an island where
presumably they bury it or something
but um jeff bishop uh you know does
there's two guys jeff bishop and jason
bond who seem to head up raging bull
now in the ad that i most often see jeff
bishop says he's the founder of
of raging bull and i remember thinking
like raging bull's been around for a
while you know and so
the internet exists you can look up who
founded
raging ball it's founded in 1998 by
three uh college roommates none of them
were jeff bishop
so that's and actually i think you could
even find his uh his linkedin cv
and it's not obvious to me that he ever
worked in any sort of uh investing role
other than sort of pitching stocks on
raging bulls so
oh my gosh that's so funny i did not
know that but now
to get to bring us back to belfort now
jordan belfort is being
pitched as some stock guy and you made
the hilario
you made some hilarious uh observation
that maybe you should just like repeat
here because i find it hilarious
because he is a salesman i will give him
he's a good salesman and that's what he
was
teaching for some time and i was like
okay at least at least
you're obviously a good salesman that's
fine i i don't really have that big of a
problem with it
but now that he's selling stocks it's
like you were arrested for what you did
with stocks
he received a four-year sentence for
securities fraud and money laundering i
believe just to be clear you know so
i kind of think that if he was setting
up teaching you how to maybe
sell a pencil on amazon you know that
that might be
you know i've i've seen the wolf of wall
street film and he seemed to be an
excellent pencil salesman but it's just
not obvious
maybe the only thing he's maybe less
suited to having watched that film is
maybe
teaching someone lamborghini maintenance
tips you know that that's the only
thing
i mean you know this is a guy in fact
amusingly as well
on his wikipedia page where you can see
i get all of my information
it says that his greatest regret he
claims is losing people's money you know
and he didn't lose people's money he
stole
people's money you know there's a
difference he didn't lose it they
lost it right yeah
he stole it and then he
he stole i believe or at least he was
required to return to his clients 110
million
um apparently 10 was paid back and that
was
through asset forfeiture and so on which
means
you know the way these guys talk about
how much money they've made or how
wealthy they are
jordan belfort it would appear to me
possibly as a net worth
of minus 100 million dollars you know
so that's who you're that's who you're
finding
yeah uh i believe that it's
i forget what the product line is called
but they're pitching it as free
but it requires a membership so it's
like yeah
well and another thing i'd recommend to
people who
might be interested in signing up for
these kinds of courses
is if you look on websites like the
better business bureau you can see
how well people have done we'll say if
they subscribe to a service and try and
cancel whether they get their money back
and so on and
you know you can find raging bull has a
you know
a score on the better business bureau
website if anyone's interested
look not up what is the score it's it's
not
five stars okay that's a nice
that's a very nice way to put it oh it's
one in that one in like a third stars
out of five
imagine so bad better business bureau
rating of f
yeah and they're not even like the
better the better business bureau
it's not even a lot of people can get
a's even being fraudulent so the fact
you have an f anytime i see an f on the
better business bureau i think
wow you must be really doing something
wrong well it means you haven't upset
some of your clients it means you've
upset most of them you know
that's right so actually i have a
question so let's say somebody
uh because i feel like this is a great
opportunity let's say somebody wants to
get into investing
first of all specifically day trading
because i made a video that made a lot
of people mad where i said day trading
you'll probably lose money
i cited a couple studies that have
looked at a bunch of day traders and
what their returns were
and as you know even the day traders who
do well
one year even two years typically
it's only a minor indication of how well
they'll do the next year
and the year after that and whatever so
i basically said look
you're better off probably unless you're
going to spend your life doing this
you're better off just investing the
market um
would you agree with that and then if
somebody wants to day trade what are
reasonable expectations like if they
actually want to learn how to do it what
are the books
maybe to look into and then also we're
talking returns here
there's some people who think they're
going to make a hundred thousand dollars
a year day trading
pretty quickly what do you think about
that okay so
there's a few things like uh because uh
you know i teach finance at a university
and a lot of the students ask me about
starting up trading you know and and to
a certain extent
i slightly say to my students it's a
good idea to have a brokerage account
and to invest some money because even
just if you
go to a job interview you know if you're
you know often you'll have someone in a
job interview and they'll say my passion
is investing in stocks and you kind of
go what stocks do you own and they go
well i don't own any
and it's like well it's it's not exactly
your passion you know
and that's alright things don't have to
be your passion but um
you know i i do say to them you know it
doesn't hurt to have an
investment account but that's different
to day trading
um i i usually advise them if they want
to sort of start this sort of thing up
is just get an excel spreadsheet and put
in the trades that you would do
and see how they work out and and that
gives you a bit of a feeling and i
you know there's some people and they
they kind of can't
play with pretend money and act like
it's real money and there
are others who really can and if you are
the kind who can
you'll you'll possibly learn quite a bit
about yourself and about risk tolerance
and things like that
um you know i i think that's a good
approach to start in truth i think for
the majority of people
day trading doesn't make sense and it's
basically based you know i did see the
video you're talking about and
i think it's entirely accurate and and
it's not me being negative but
you know the reason you know i do a lot
of short-term trading but i have very
good
uh relationships with brokers and that
kind of thing where i trade very cheaply
and it's not like um
you know some of the trading apps tell
you they don't charge you a commission
but you know people make money one way
or another and if they
don't charge you a commission but route
your your trades to
you know a high frequency trader they've
been well compensated for this you know
so i i can you break that down a little
bit for people because they're thinking
okay no it's a no commission how can i
you know once again there's kind of the
you know the basic rule of economics
there's no such thing as a free laundry
but essentially firstly a lot of these
brokerage firms are actually
they're not making the money they used
to because they've brought their
commissions
close to zero but high frequency trading
firms will pay them to send
those trades into the pool in fact the
guy who invented
this thing of paying for flow was bernie
madoff interestingly enough
but um he had another business besides
ponzi schemes but
um and uh and interestingly when i was
at university we did a case study on
whether bernie madoff was a fraud but it
was
it wasn't whether he was afraid whether
his business was ethical because it was
about rerouting trades like this
uh we deemed it not ethical we just
didn't know how unethical it was
this is before this is before yeah oh
that's so funny
in 2004 there's a business school case
study out there you can find you know
um but uh you know
in terms of why the problem with day
trading is
we'll say for example if you start out
like even if you have a good amount of
money you've got a million dollars and
you want to
invest that in day trade um
a good year might give you sort of a 10
maybe 20 return which is one to 200
000 a year you know and that's great but
there are also
months and days and years when you will
have
uh horrible returns you know and that's
just the way it is and look at the
greatest investors out there and their
returns and you'll see
that there are you know even multi-year
periods of terrible returns and you have
to
sort of still put food on the table
throughout those those difficult periods
and you have to stick with it through
those periods
if that's reasonable and so
that's if you start out with we'll say a
million dollars most of the people who
are talking about doing this or talking
about starting out with a lot
less money and the problem is if you if
you start out with 10
000 and want to make 10 000 a year
you know you have to double they want to
make 10 000 a month are you kidding well
that that won't happen because it you
know it's kind of like saying you know
go to vegas and you can make ten
thousand
uh in a month and it's like if you're
lucky but the long run
expectation is that you will lose all of
it you know and
and that's another problem i have with a
lot of the sort of fake gurus is that
you know i watched a video uh uh uh i
think
uh jeff bishop video on options the
other day and i have a bit of expertise
i've written a book on
pricing derivatives and that sort of
thing and
his video was firstly filled with errors
to be clear
but then on top of that he was saying
that the beauty of
investing using options is that uh you
know you can
you can ten times leave for your money
so instead of if the market moves up ten
percent
you'll you'll make uh you'll double your
money you know and that's great and it's
like he doesn't mention
or he kind of glosses over that if it
moves against you at all that you will
materially uh you know lose everything
yeah and and and that this
this is expected to happen like this
and not only that then he also advocates
the most volatile stocks like when he
says you could trade and he lists out
five stocks and they're all like the
most volatile things and not only have
you
found the craziest thing but then you're
you're levering it ten times
he made these other errors where he said
that um
you know when you buy an option that
that it's made up of intrinsic value and
time
value and the time value is the amount
that you can lose and it's like no
you know when you sign up to trade
options you sign a disclosure degree uh
disclosure that states that you can lose
more than you invest and that is
that is the truth that's what you can
lose is more than the initial capital
but on to like whether people should day
trade or not i think
it's reasonable for people to learn
about finance and to invest i think it's
reasonable to start out small not
ten times levered and i also think
um that the the other thing you have to
look at is sort of your lost earnings
from other things you know because
when these guys are sort of sitting on a
beach with a laptop claiming to make two
percent a day
i i i don't leave the office i haven't
had a holiday in
five no probably eight years since i've
had a holiday
okay yeah but but patrick respectfully
that's because you actually do this for
a living
well these people don't these these
people don't actually do it they just
sell it and so part of their job
is to show up on the beach with a
photograph with a photo
photographer and that's their job is to
sell the lifestyle of this so-called
mysterious
day but you're out here saying look if
you actually want to do this for real
for real
you're not taking a day off you're it's
hard and grueling work
it is emotionally stressful you know
because
whenever things go well you feel like a
genius and when things go badly you feel
like the world's greatest
idiot and a fraud you know you look at
yourself and you're like why did i just
i could
i could have done other things with my
life
and that that was actually a point i was
getting to is that you know for a lot of
people
if you want to talk about like should i
i remember in the late
90s there was a friend of mine who
uh her husband shut down his dental
practice to become a day trader because
he could make
more money trading stocks than he could
working as a dentist but
you have to look at the the income
you've given up by doing this as well
you know like if you
um if you quit your job to be a
day trader the problem is you know you
you have to make the amount of money
that you need
to feed yourself for one thing um which
might not be easy and secondly you don't
have like any steady
income coming in so there's opportunity
cost also your cv
isn't if you're young because i feel a
lot of this stuff is pitched at quite
young
people and oh yeah you know it's all on
instagram and things like that where
you know no one over the age of 30 as
has ever logged in you know
and um you know the the thing is that
it uh it's misleading as to you know you
don't just damage you don't just
lose some of your savings you can also
sort of harm your career and
it's it's prob you know a funny one when
i launched my fund
i had worked in the in the investment
management
business for probably around 15 years at
that point
and i was slow to launch my business
because i'd seen
so many people like good smart people
that i knew
start up and then it just doesn't go
very well and they spent
five years kind of breaking even or
making a little bit of money but never
enough
and they're kind of never able to go
back to doing a real job again because
there's always this hope that it's going
to work
you know and i i really waited until
firstly i was able to start with a
reasonable amount of capital
but secondly even that that i had sort
of
you know i had 15 years of trading
experience including through the
financial crisis and sort of stressful
situations before because you know
someone who's honest with themselves
also asks are my returns random and it's
not always
you know it's not always obvious we'll
say for example even you know when i
brought up that soros and buffett have
amongst the best records out there
you know the truth is there's a lot of
people trading stocks right
they'll always be two people would like
if it was a coin flipping contest
there would always be two people with
weird records that
are way outliers that they're just
always seeming to win
it's just the nature of random and you
know a funny thing um
because i i worked for vic niederhoffer
and and he
met occasionally george soros and saurus
would um
soros was stressed about this you know
he would never put himself forth as
someone with genius ideas you know
victor used to say that at the end of
the year
soros would would be dejected and say
you know i'm out of ideas i don't know
what to do and victor would say well
you've just had a 100 return last year
this is
you know you're the greatest trader in
the world and source would go yeah but
that was then you know i i don't know
that i have that anymore
and that's how a real person thinks
that's these guys don't you know
one of the things i would say if you
want to try and differentiate between a
fake guru and someone who's really
knowledgeable
is just look at how they behave because
they behave
quite differently you know like if you
look at how
you know look at the sort of forbes uh
wealthiest people in the world and how
they behave and then look at how these
guys are like
sort of flashing their lamborghinis and
you know a bookshelf in the garage
because that's where you keep books
and um you know like this is not how
normal people behave and i think they've
kind of triggered in all of these like
little psychological reactions like
they've worked out how to make you
jealous and they've worked out
and instagram i think is just an amazing
jealousy machine
you know that's true it's it's main
function is just to make people
constantly jealous of each other exactly
and these guys just they show you
all of this kind of crazy kind of
lifestyles of the rich and famous or mtv
cribs lifestyle and tell you a year ago
i was just like you and it's
it's not really believable but gosh you
know people like to dream you know like
i i
understand why people sort of fall for
it you know
yeah absolutely and one thing i'd also
like to say is one way you can
differentiate i mean this is my humble
opinion
you should tell me if you agree or
disagree is i feel like
people who understand what they're doing
don't dumb it down and make it seem
easier than it is
trading is extraordinarily difficult if
you want to achieve
a outsized alpha
um you know repeatedly and so
i think that what people i you know when
i when i see your videos
i'm not seeing how to make all this
money so quick
it's like sort of like fundamental
principles of this
statistics you know all these kind of
basic techniques
and those are the basics i mean that's
just even to get your feet wet in the
field
but if you actually want to do real work
you have to underst uh understand it to
an even more technical level
i think so what do you what do you
think when you see all these people
doing so much technical analysis and
just like constantly trading just
candlesticks and stuff like that do you
what do you i mean what do you think of
that well uh a funny thing is that you
know as i told you when i started that
first job and i i
sort of expected to be told all these
trading strategies and people said to me
no go and find your own trading
strategies
so step one was to go to a bookshelf and
to take down all of these technical
analysis
books and so i sat there and
methodically tested them and in
particular actually candlesticks they're
the easiest to test because it's just
open high low close data right
and so you and there's often just three
candlesticks in there right so you can
take
that sort of pattern and run it through
uh all the stock market data that you
want to and see if it works or not
and amazingly like i was almost
surprised
how because even according to randomness
you'd expect like some of it to work
better but it was
there were very few things that had any
sort of a sharp ratio at all and many of
them that were sort of supposed to be
bullish signals were were bearish
signals and so on and so it's actually
giving you the opposite
it's like actually doing worse than you
expect from just even randomness
exactly and you know the problem like
one of the problems
with being a day trader with short-term
trading is
that you you firstly you're running up a
lot of trading costs it's expensive to
trade
even on top of like not only do you have
these high trading costs
but you also then have it's all
short-term gains right which is taxed at
a terrible rate and
you know the investments no one ever
tells you that no one ever tells you
that
no and in truth i don't even think it's
reasonable like i don't know why a
short-term gain is worse than the
long-term gain but that's the tax code
and it's the tax code in most countries
now the kind of people because what i do
is short-term trading
there's certain tax advantages in
futures but not only that the kind of
people who invest with me are usually
people who have non-taxable accounts so
there are certain strategies that might
make sense in a retirement account that
don't make sense in
your regular account and you know these
are all subtleties like
you know jason bonder whoever isn't
going to tell you this stuff
you know but this this an interesting
one like even
when i was at university when the first
studies i did was to look at the
behavior of stock prices around their
dividend
dates right the idea was that a stock
that pays a dividend if it pays a one
dollar dividend
you'd expect it to fall by one dollar in
value right
and and the problem is that the dividend
is taxed at one rate and so you would
think that that maybe there might be an
arbitrage in there that you could buy
dividend paying stocks will say in your
retirement account
and that you could buy non-dividend
paying in fact i think it's a great idea
still
that you could split your retirement
account of the dividend payers
and your regular account of the
non-dividend payers and then you're tax
efficient you know but
that's a smart kind of quantitative
trade that's not there's no way
investing
guru telling you to do things like that
right right that's like this like
subtlety with the tax code where you can
kind of like cheat out a little bit of
extra income
and yeah no no no well each other
gutierrez isn't going to tell you this
actually that's the problem is that
almost any good
trading strategy often involves detailed
knowledge like it involves knowing
uh all of the rules of the markets how
they open how they close like
why people do certain things like there
might be
certain trading strategies that would be
driven by
we'll say for example i did a video a
little while ago on index
ads and deletes you know relating to
tesla possibly getting added to the s
p and there there are all kinds of ideas
you can come to based around
little technical things like that but
that's that's
more work than sort of in fact there's
one
guy i wish i knew his name like he has
the worst possible
he's one of the bag of money guys you
know and he has these videos where it
shows like
stock price going up and stock price
going down he's like what i'll teach is
how to buy when it's going up and so
when it's going down
other people do the opposite and it's
like it's amazing that he's worked out
he's worked out this trick you know
it's like a magic trick i know it's like
i feel like these people are like
magicians trying to convince you that
magic is real when really they kind of
have a con
going on behind the scenes and they're
basically just fooling their audience
and then the people sort of in the know
are like do not fall for these guys
they're like selling you a lie
so okay let's just because i
absolutely things aren't black and white
but let's say somebody's sitting out
there
they have an account size of less than
a hundred thousand dollars and they're
saying
patrick i see that you've got experience
i see that you teach university
yes or no should i try day trading or
should i just forget about it as a
primary income i think it would be a
horrible mistake you know because your
expected return off of that
is is zero right because it just it will
say if you're exposed to randomness your
expected return is zero and that's just
mathematically right
we'll say if you happen to have an edge
you might you know then look at all the
like the the good hedge funds out there
and their returns you know 20
a year for buffett and source right so
if you're as good as buffett and source
which
chances are you're maybe not um
your return is 20 000 a year you need to
get a job do you know what i mean like
because you'll earn more if you're the
kind of person who's able to save up a
hundred thousand dollars
you're probably a high enough earner
that earning twenty thousand a year and
also then it gets taxed as short-term
gains so the government takes half of it
away from well
you'll be in a lower tax bracket but you
know being in a lower tax bracket is its
own problem
yeah right having not enough income is
definitely its own
you it's it's its own unique set of
challenges uh i'm glad you say that said
that get a job that's what i always say
all these people
are trying to they they really dismiss
jobs like they're like yeah you
shouldn't be a guy with a job it's
they hate jobs it is a sort of a
disgusting thing like the revolt they
have for like
people who do real things you don't work
there's one of them
there's one of the ads and it kicks in
with like i remember the day my boss
told me he was giving me a
five percent pay cut and i told him to
stuff it so you know it
starts out like that but it's all um you
know
like there's there's such a scorn like
it's kind of like look at me and my
lamborghini i have such
scorn for someone who works hard to put
you know food on the table of his family
you know
this is terrible it's terrible and then
they go yeah this is realistic come sign
up for my stupid
course which is the reason he owns the
lamborghini and the only way he can pay
for it
and then you go sign up you get less
than expected returns and once again
when i say like look at how these people
behave and how
actually wealthy people behave like i've
i've
i've been fortunate in my career i've
met a lot of some of the wealthier
people around
and i've never heard them be dismissive
of a person's
work because it's work that work
generates wealth you know like it's
it's really like if you if you can do
something
that helps someone that makes their life
better they will pay you for that and
even that's my business
like i invest money for people and i do
a type of analysis that is frankly
grueling and unpleasant to do
and i trade it and people will pay me to
do that but like
if you're not it's sort of uh doing
stuff that makes the world but you know
my old boss once again vic needer offer
had these t-shirts printed up that said
add value on them you know
and he felt that that was the route to
all success in life is if you are adding
that it's even like if you have a
youtube channel
if you have a channel that that is that
some people can watch and get some value
out of it then it's worthwhile if it's
only for you it's maybe
less it's not going to grow and it's
also not necessarily worth it
it's not worth your time maybe
yeah and that's a lot of what these
people are doing is they're they're
taking they're trying to teach like
short cuts
to getting more wealth than you actually
even are cr like you're not actually
doing anything so why do you expect to
create this wealth so there's kind of a
mismatch of you're expecting to turn a
hundred dollars into
a hundred thousand but you know nothing
about the stock market prior to this
guy's course and it's like he's supposed
to take you there come on get real
well it's even uh you know the the kind
of these people telling you
you can make a fortune like buying stuff
and selling it on amazon and it's like
you know the the most famous quote of
jeff bezos is is
uh your margin is is my profit
opportunity or he's got it's got some
line like that where and everyone is
terrified that amazon will
enter the business they're in because
they grind the margins
down to zero yeah and for some reason
people think that jeff bezos has
left all of this fat for them to eat you
know
anything it's just no no hold on that is
the craziest thing
i always tell people this i'm like you
think amazon
fba is the greatest opportunity you're
talking about the most
most ruthless businessman probably the
21st century has ever seen
and you're saying that that guy is going
to make you like
a millions and millions of dollars
without dry
basically grinding your bones and
sucking as much blood as he can out of
you you've got to be kidding
it's insane and not only that but also
there's kind of this idea like
i i think what they often do as well is
they rename a business something else
like
you had the term they use there for like
amazon something
something you know yeah it's just drop
shipping you know they call it that
because what it is
is opening a shop on the internet you
know like if you're
buying stuff we'll say cheaply from a
manufacturer
and selling it to someone else that's a
shop that's called a shop
you're now competing with walmart and
target but they have
actual shops you don't even have your
own website you're using jeff bezos's
website
you're gonna get rich
uh yeah i mean it's it's absolutely
hilarious
so for people who are like okay well how
can i make the stock market work for me
because obviously
how these people get away with doing
this is because everyone knows the stock
market itself
is not a scam there are ways to make
people make fortunes on the stock market
they just don't make it overnight
so i usually recommend that people do
things like
index funds just really safe super low
fee
strategies things where you can get
95 of the value let's say out of the
stock market with basically doing
no work at all um that's how i usually
advise how do you when when you look at
things
people average everyday people who are
just like how do i get the most out of
this
without basically subjecting myself to
extraordinary risk
or um extraordinary amounts of time that
aren't may not pay off for me let's just
say they don't want to be a professional
investor
what do you do with your money what are
your recommendations you know i i would
advise people firstly to
to put money when don't even look at it
like so when you invest it don't even
look at it like
if it's for your retirement if it's in
30 years time start looking at it in
about 25 years you know but just
put it as you say in a low-cost uh
mutual fund like place like vanguard or
they all provide them right if you want
to mix it up and sort of use your head a
little bit more like if the purely
passive approach doesn't appeal to you
you know all of those big index fund
services provide a bunch of indexes
right and you can probably
improve your diversification by maybe
adding like
uh opportunity like you may be sometimes
uh
you know in recent years uh growth
stocks you know all the technology stuff
has done really well
in other periods value stocks like kind
of the more boring companies do well
you know you might want to um you know
if
if you have if you feel that you can add
value you might allocate a little bit
differently between those rather than
just a pure index fund you might
want to you know buy an international
mutual fund or uh emerging markets or
something like that
if you feel there's been a big sell-off
in that area if it makes sense
but that's kind of as active you know
the stock market is a great thing and it
really
is the route to well well
it it can be the route to growing your
wealth but
in that when you invest in stocks what
you do is you own a business or you own
part of a business and you should expect
the kind of returns that a business will
get
um you know so if if you're invested in
amazon you should expect the kind of
returns that amazon will get or whatever
and so sorry no problem
so you know investing in stocks is a
good way of growing your wealth
i think it should i think everyone
should invest just to be clear
but i think that that you need to do it
with an amount of money that doesn't
stress you like
if if you are staring at the daily moves
it probably means that you've exposed
yourself to too much risk you know if
you're afraid of it and just
back your size down um there's a
a friend of mine who is a big fund
manager and he
um he refers to the stock market as
being a lot like a casino but he says
you have the great fortune of being on
the correct side of the tables you know
because
over the long run the stock market grows
we'll say at about five percent
greater than the risk-free rater than
what you'd earn in bonds right
and you get to put your money in and be
like the house and sort of have the edge
in your favor
but then what you do is you just put it
in and you leave it in and
and often you know we all have these
faults
um we all have uh urges to do things
differently and they often harm us
in in the world of investing you know
and a great example actually the same
guy he did
he uh i'll send you a link later he
wrote a paper on a coin flipping
game and it was set up that the
the students who did it were told that
the coins would flip i think
60 percent of the time you'd have a
heads right
and you get to bet on it and you wanted
to see how well people bet on this
is this argument or is this burton
malcolm
no this is uh his name he's actually one
of the
partners from long-term capital
management victor hagani
okay um and and another friend of mine
you and kirk wrote a really good kind of
follow-up paper on it but
you've got a coin flipping contest
you've been told that you have a 60
chance of winning if you flip if you bet
on heads every time
and he really wanted to see whether
people sized accurately because if
if you bet too much of your bankroll on
that you will still go bankrupt there's
actually kind of a
a formula the kelly formula for
correctly sizing your bets that
is a kind of quant trader idea or a
gambling idea
but so he wanted to see how close to
like the kelly optimal bed
regular people came to and he was
shocked because he found that a lot of
the time
there were people and after a long run
of heads they would bet on tails because
they just felt
it's time for tails to come up you know
and there's sort of a thing where we
want to
express ourselves like our prove our our
abilities and often that's harmful
you know like when you've been told the
winning strategy a lot of people can't
stick with the winning strategy they go
with the losing strategy because they go
i i just want to be different or i want
to be
[Music]
maybe they think it's time for it's time
for tails
for change and and they sort of feel
that
that that will prove that the return is
about them
rather than that it's sort of a return
that they're harvesting and in the real
world like even all of my quan trading
it's about harvesting returns like i
find a return stream it's a risky return
stream
always by the way there's no such thing
as a risk-free high returns
i find these return streams
and i try and harvest them and then i
try and find more of them
and basically like when someone invests
in something like a hedge fund
firstly you shouldn't really usually
invest in a hedge fund
unless you've got tons of money that's
already in the stock market
and then you kind of say what could
smooth out my returns
and and the way i would tell an investor
what you get from a hedge fund is
actually
uncorrelated returns you know where
you're you get
access to a return stream that's not
easily available
that isn't tied necessarily to the
return of the s p 500
but it's not a better return stream it's
not a risk-free return stream
it's different and by being different
it's sort of if you look at the
sort of correlation mathematics it
should overall give you a better risk
return trade-off but
because you're trying to basically
diversify out your risk exactly it just
gives you diversification so even it's
like private equity and hedge funds
you know you might get a better return
out of them but what you should be
aiming to get out of them is
diversification
from the easily available good returns
that are available with a stock market
investment
i i would expect that to go over a lot
of people who
barely understand the stock market i
expect some of that to go over people's
heads
but those of you at home if you
understood that that is a
amazing kind of nugget of wisdom there
um
because what people are looking for a
lot of the times
is some uncorrelated market and it's so
hard to get an uncorrelated rate of
return
a lot of times nowadays because markets
are so highly correlated something that
happens in america
oftentimes will affect markets in china
and stuff and so
people are constantly if you're really
in the market you're looking for some
sort of thing to diversify your risk
away
and so that's really interesting i i
personally did not know that i've
often wondered what is the what is the
like real draw to hedge funds so that's
something for me to take away if people
are super interested in this i have a
playlist that's put up i think it's
called
applied portfolio management and no one
watches it on youtube because it's about
six one-hour videos because people don't
actually want to learn the stock market
they just want to they just want the
hype of like i'm a trader they want to
say
i'm a trader they want to say i day
trade they want to say
i've got forex life they want to talk
about the lifestyle but nobody
actually cares to understand anything
nobody actually cares to actually go and
research
and do the work to understand what they
so-called
are investing in or talking well even
like two two of those six videos they go
through
what hedge fund strategies are and i
kind of explain like
okay so merger arbitrage when two peop
companies are combining
there might be an opportunity this is
how it works this is the return
statement
so if you're super interested in this
stuff you know you can watch
six to 12 hours of content on my channel
that no one else watches but uh
i love it no i i love and that actually
is a true taste of whether you like
trading
because most people love the idea of
trading again just to be clear
mo but actually trading most people
don't
wouldn't find it that interesting
because really good trading
is a grind it's oftentimes boring it's
oftentimes about
finding something and then doing it over
and over again yeah
because once you find something why
would you it's repetitive you know
there's a
another book i would recommend to people
there's this edward
torp a man for all markets and he's a
fascinating guy he um
he's the guy who kind of cracked
blackjack you know all those blackjack
systems back in the 60s
then he turned to markets and found all
these market efficiencies
uh so he wrote two books beat the dealer
was the gambling one beat
wall street i think was the the stock
market one then this is sort of uh
his life story it's a great story but
like
you get the real feeling of what it is
to be an investor reading
you know an another book and now i'm
just talking about books but there's
no no no this is what people need to
hear yeah go ahead well actually what i
would say is if you want to learn how to
make money you can just read an awful
lot of books your work for tai lopez
and um you know
you guys you know some of these jokes
are
really decriminally underrated here this
is some good jokes you're dropping some
heat right
now it's good
but there's um there's a great book
called shoe dog
by i think his name is phil knight you
know the guy who's founded nike
and he describes like why it's the best
book i've read on like what it's like to
run a business and it's a grind and he
talks about like the
the toll it took on his family and
dealing with bankers and dealing with
suppliers who try and rip you off and
all of the
like you know what everyone wants all
this money that that people say is
freely available
everyone wants it and they'll fight you
to the death for it you know and so
no one is going to give you these ideas
because they want it for themselves
and equally if there was something easy
out there
someone else would grab it like why why
wouldn't people make will say like a
copy of a louis vuitton handbag and sell
it
if it's not profitable right so not only
do you have to sort of have the product
but then someone will copy it and rip it
off
and people will you know there's just
there's hundreds of
like everyone is out to make the money
that's out there because
people need it you know people need to
feed themselves you know
and and it's not it's it's not easy and
it shouldn't be easy
very well said um let's
close this by talking i i like what you
said i like that you're bringing up
books because ultimately that's what i'm
constantly preaching on the show i'm
like
you guys are buying two thousand dollar
courses you haven't even cracked your
local library once yeah i mean are you
kidding me you say you want
knowledge but you've never gotten your
library card out um
or much or god forbid spend ten dollars
you know on a kindle book or something
like that
so that is the way i see to most
deep knowledge is i really see it in
books
even there are incredible like obviously
there are you're making
great videos and stuff like that but i
think the best way to condense
information is still in print yeah i
don't think videos
quite crack the educational market
because i think video trends towards
entertainment
rather than information in a weird way
um
which is just a talk for another time so
i want you to recommend some books for
people who
actually are in this and they say okay i
do still want to learn
but i maybe shouldn't follow these gurus
what should i do
what should i read firstly there's
there's a bunch like george soros you
know one of the greatest traitors ever
has written about ten books there's guys
like
howard marx wrote a really good book
it's called um
i can't you know what i'll do i'll
rather than me try and list from my
faulty memory a bunch of books i'll send
you
uh kind of like a reading list that you
can stick on the bottom of uh
of your uh that sounds perfect that
sounds absolutely perfect
um and people can find you at patrick
boyle
yeah on youtube you have 5 000
subscribers which is just
insane to me these idiots
these scammers have like millions of
subscribers
i'm gonna photocopy some big wads of
money and carry them around
and wave them and i think that's the
it's just so insane it drives me
nuts but if you actually care about
finance you wanna learn
um you know you're a really good
resource where else
do you do you have some other channels
you like to follow that you think are
good um
you know there's a really good uh what
is the guy called it's
uh you know once again let me email you
but there's a guy that's called donut
something he has this great channel um
but i
i can't remember oh i think i've seen
this guy
i think he's out of canada or something
like that it's like
oh man it's like yeah i know what you're
talking about it's like half
donut one donut finance or something
something like that
i know this guy oh
shoot he was talking it's high quality
and it's also
uh you know it's little animation like
it's watchable
and educational
absolutely i'm man i'm it's really
making me frustrated not being able to
find this guy because i've also seen him
and i also thought at the same time i
was like oh this is really good
uh yeah just send it to me we'll get
we'll get all the links up
thank you so much for coming on patrick
i really appreciate it and i think uh
pleasure to speak to you thank you for
clearing up the myths
on in the stock market and and uh day
trading appreciate it
[Music]
okay
[Music]
comes along